>> Okay. So, we have out text editor.
We're ready to make changes to code, but we
need to get it. And from the searching
I did earlier, I gather we're going to use GitHub.
>> Yep.
>> And what is that? What is GitHub?
>> It's a version control system that let's you keep track of
changes that you make to your code and let's people collaborate easily.
>> Okay, I know, I mean, at Udacity you engineers
are using it, and what are you guys doing with GitHub?
>> Yeah, so basically at Udacity we have one, like,
main master branch that everybody uses as sort of
the, the source of truth. And then people will make
branches to that their own separate branches that they
then make changes on. And then submit pull requests back
to everybody else, and everybody else can, can look
at it. Usually there's one particular code reviewer who will
approve the change or say, you know, maybe you
need, you know, you should change this here or there.
>> Okay.
>> Change this variable and, whatever.
>> Okay. So for
our purposes, we're not going to be, like, merging anything back into
>> Right.
>> The original code. What are we going to do?
>> Yeah. So, for our purposes, we're just going to check out
the main branch, make some changes, and leave it at that.
>> That's going to be our own new thing now.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, cool, so let's install GitHub.
>> Sounds good.